Welcome to Module Nine — time-series forecasting.
Sequential data has rules of its own, and breaking them quietly ruins models.
We'll cover preprocessing, windowing, model choices, multi-step forecasting, and anomaly detection.
Always plot the series first — look for trend, seasonality, and sudden level shifts.
Differencing removes a trend; seasonal decomposition splits the signal into trend, seasonal, and residual parts; rolling mean and standard deviation let you eyeball stationarity.
And never scale using statistics from the full series — that leaks the future into your training set.
To learn from it, you reframe the series as supervised samples.
Slide a window of length L across the data: the past L steps are your inputs, the next step or next few are the target.
Choose expanding or rolling windows, split by time rather than shuffling, and size the window to a meaningful look-back.
Now pick a model.
A one-D CNN is fast and catches local patterns.
An LSTM remembers longer context but costs you speed, and a bidirectional LSTM sees the whole window.
Attention and Transformers scale to long sequences, and a sequence-to-sequence encoder–decoder handles multi-step output — but a simple naive or SARIMA baseline still has to be beaten.
Forecasting several steps ahead has three flavors.
Direct trains one model per horizon.
Recursive feeds predictions back as inputs, so errors compound.
Seq2seq emits the whole horizon in one pass, and probabilistic models like DeepAR and the Temporal Fusion Transformer also give you calibrated uncertainty.
Finally, anomaly detection.
Train a model — often an LSTM autoencoder — to reconstruct normal windows.
When reconstruction error spikes, you've found an anomaly; threshold it by a validation-set quantile, and let VAE variants give you calibrated scores.
Let's build some forecasters — open the labs.